hey what's going down my name is the
China's first time I've shared my intro
probably the last time as well but
welcome to episode 92 off game
programming so we're gonna talk about
some very very very basic AI okay
because I want to start off basic and
very advanced so sorry last time we left
off with um with this animated sprite
stuff and actually making our dummy a
guy move again will kind of move right
not really move just um basically just
well we gave him the ability to move but
not the not not the artificial
intelligence not the intelligence to
decide how he wants to move okay but we
gave him the ability to move course then
you can see it's moving down right now
which is pretty awesome and that's the
only direction you can go right now so
we're gonna change that right after I
put a strawberry into my mouth mm-hmm
pretty good um yeah so as you can see
I'm pretty professional with my
programming stars I thought about that I
I just made you guys sit through meeting
a strawberry anyway so um right so to do
that we need to actually give him a
bunch of if statements here they
basically say if this is happening move
this way if this is happening move this
way right so we're gonna give him some
very basic AI and I really like this
type of AI and the reason is it really
it's really good for ambience okay and
what I mean by that is sometimes you
just want entities or mobs specifically
and your NPCs that basically just they
just exist right then they might that is
there to kind of make your world feel a
little bit more lively okay and they
have no purpose okay they don't go
anywhere like I said they don't have a
set task they have to do that on enemy
they're not gonna attack you they're
just there literally for the environment
right for ambience and because of that
we don't have a pretty find a a ice kind
of structure that we want them to
actually follow right we don't have like
a okay if the player gets this close
beat him to death no we don't have that
stuff right or um you know make sure you
go to this Waypoint and do that go to
then go to this Web
that if the player gives you $600 then
given this you know we don't have any of
that stuff right the only thing that um
is going on these guys are just there
just to kind of fill up our ambience
okay and because of that we want to kind
of set an AI script here that that
essentially just um you know just just
makes them kind of we don't want them
standing still we just kind of want them
to move kind of subtle you know I'm just
um I'm just kind of exist okay
so what we're gonna cover today is
basically how to do that okay it's a
very basic random our movement okay so
right now we have this this poor little
King Cherno here who's standing up to a
next to Jesus over here in a suit and we
want him to just kind of you know move
over there maybe stand over there for a
while then change direction maybe move
over here and you know you know
something like that okay so the way we
can do that is first of all we need to
make a variable here called time okay
and we're gonna set that equal to zero
and basically as long as the guy's alive
well said we'll just increment his time
okay and because it's in the update
method this will be equivalent to
incrementing this time variable 60 times
per second so every second this time
variable will be in multiple of 60
that's how it's going to work and so
because of that that doesn't really tell
us much but that that just makes sure
that for example if you do something
like time mod 60 right or time you know
if you really cool time and 59 that will
actually be equivalent to 1 once per
second so that that's kind of gonna give
you a measurement okay um of time here
so time mod 60 will be actually equal to
one second so in other words if you set
something to happen when time mod 60
equals zero well I'm sorry that very bad
phrasing here time mod 60 is not gonna
give you zero oh sorry it's not gonna
give you one second what I mean is that
time one sixty if time 160 will equal
zero that's gonna happen once per second
as long as we keep incrementing this
time variable 60 times per second like
so when time was six equals zero that is
one second again so that's kind of how
we're gonna measure this stuff okay
now I've covered that let's make him
basically move so what we can do here is
say that if time for example this is
just to give you guys some bit of a just
a bit of knowledge as to how this is
gonna work
so if time odds 60 equals zero which is
just what I explained this is this is
the event that will happen once per
second so maybe just for now let's make
him change direction once per second so
we'll make XA plus plus here sorry let's
move again to make sure that um this
stuff is before our index aim in y8
declarations will make XA plus plus and
we'll say that um hmm so what we might
want to do here is not actually set them
to zero every frame let's move these
into X&Y declarations up to the top here
so they are class variables and the
reason is if we keep creating them as
local variables every update it's
obviously going to set them to zero so
what we'll do is we'll make XA be plus
plus here or rather we'll set X a to be
equal to one okay and we'll say that if
time or maybe I don't want to do that
way all I want to do here is let's
actually set XA equal to one to begin
with okay and what I'm going to do is I
want to say that if time mod 60 is equal
to zero so once per second let's reverse
his X direction so XA x equals negative
one okay
or you can obviously do it XA equals
negative XA same thing right let's
actually do it this way so what this
will do is once per second it will
actually change the direction so let's
let's hit the debug button and we'll see
what that looks like
okay just R then you can see the
animation is still a bit dodgy haven't
fixed that yet but that's what it's
gonna do so he's gonna roam left and
right okay and once per second he's
gonna change his direction if we change
this mod here to be 120 you can imagine
that it's gonna happen once every two
seconds so it's gonna move that way two
seconds pauses is going to change
direction
two seconds boss is going to change
direction again okay that's how about
that that's basically how that kind of
works okay and we can obviously do the
same thing for y so y equals negative Y
except let's
initialize it with one okay and there is
sorry I must have X is still set to 1
let's set that back to 0 so he's gone up
and he's gone down okay
very very simple okay wouldn't really
call this AI either but it's um it's
very simple okay that's kind of how this
is the basis of how this is gonna work
so instead of us going ahead and saying
yeah okay let's change this direction to
something that's predictable we can use
Javas random class to actually randomize
this a bit so instead of this what we
can say is is instead of this if time
let's just say once per second at least
for now is equal to zero then let's set
XA equal to random dot next int three
okay now what what is that gonna do
let's talk about what this is gonna do
random dot dot next int with the
parameter of three will actually choose
an integer obviously if this a random
dot next int it will choose an integer
between zero and two so in other words
it will give us a number that is either
0 1 or 2
now that doesn't really help us much
because X if X a is 2 well he's just
gonna be moving horizontally a lot
faster right that's not gonna help us we
don't want it to be too what we do want
it want X a to be because remember
before x and y a our possible values
here not this is just excluding speed by
the way our possible values are negative
1 0 & 1 right if it is negative 1 we are
moving left if it is 0 we are stationary
on the app on the x axis and if we are
if XA is positive 1 then we are moving
right so what we can do is actually just
subtract 1 from this and what that's
gonna do is this will give us a number
between 0 sorry this will give this
random dot next int 3 will give us
either 0 1 or 2 and no matter what it
gives us that value will be subtracted
by 1 which basically translates XA to
have the value of either negative 1 0 or
1 okay and we can do the same thing for
let's just not do the same thing right
now let's just check out let's just
check out what this looks like so if we
hit debug
yeah let's set y equal to zero so so he
starts off here then he moves and then
he stops as you can see then he moves
further then it might move left maybe
doesn't really feel like it move right
there we go
so yeah you can see that this kind of as
this kind of you know this kind of has
some pretty weird behavior here right
once per second he will actually change
his direction or iorry could just stop
as you can see he does that okay let's
let's do the same thing for y a so why a
equals random dot next int 3 minus 1 all
right and let's check out let's check
that out
so a stationary I'll decide to go here
no it's better be this way nice moving
this way now moving this way now moving
this way now just going that way it's
completely random okay
and the cool thing about this is that um
he hasn't actually stopped yet uh-huh
but the cool thing about this is that it
actually gives him a it gives him some
life okay and to make him stop if we
just wanted him because that guy in my
opinion was moving a bit too fast we
could just say that if a random dot next
int let's just say um let's just say he
has a 1 in 5 chance to actually just
stop so if random the next into 5 equals
zero then we'll just set X a equal to 0
and y equal to 0 okay simple as that and
we might actually just move this up here
into this method just so that it happens
once every 60 seconds sorry once every
second here so you might move a bit
it'll stop you know move this way
and then he might stop hopefully there
we go yeah that might be a bit not
freaking enough for like a three okay so
there's a pretty strong chance here of
just stopping you can see does that okay
so that's pretty basic now the only
thing that I'm not a big fan of here is
the fact that obviously he cake he only
has the ability to actually change once
every second right so that's very
predictable we know that only once per
second will he change where it's going
so instead of doing that we could of
course speed up the speed of where she
does that if we set time to be mod 5 or
something then what you'll see here is
that he just figured you know he kind of
like started all over the place and the
reason is he's getting random values all
the time so the more you decrease this
the less smooth his walking will be the
more you do the more you decrease the
value that you mod this time variable by
so what we could do is actually set the
I guess the interval of time by which
she changes direction to be a random
value so random dot next int let's see
here
so we want it to be within reason we
want it to probably be okay well we want
it to at least be 20 right we don't want
it to change direction fast faster than
say I don't know 20 faster than 3 times
per second okay any faster than 3 times
per second is kind of too fast to change
direction if a time actually pulls up to
30 and then over here what variation do
we want to get give to that 30 so it
will be at least 30 but how much more
than 30 will it be that's what we can
change so maybe if we put 40 in here for
example if I'm just gonna put 15 here if
we put 50 in here what that means is
that he will actually have a random
chance to change direction either
essentially between 30 or 80 here so
we've given them so time will be modeled
by 8 by anywhere between 30 and 80 now
what that will give us is essentially
the maximum ability to change direction
twice per second or the minimum he will
at least change direction pretty much
well just just over one
second probably about 1.2 ish every 1.2
seconds okay
and that will be random every time so
let's check out what that looks like
crash a crash or exception hmm okay make
sure that you um let's let's put this in
brackets to make sure that it's because
the reason to give it gave us an
arithmetic exception is probably cuz it
gave us zero and of course you can't
divide by zero here so make sure that um
that it's modding by this entire
equation not just by random the next in
50 and then it's having 30 again let's
launch that again so yeah there he goes
and he has a high chance to say steel
let's get rid of this right now so let
this random the next and three business
let's comment that out for now so the
reason all stationary so he's moving you
know he has a random chance to change
direction you can see it's pretty uh
whoa well that collision kind of failed
there didn't it looks like he's offset
by one tile for some reason we'll fix
that up later all right
and yeah so you can see how that's kind
of working out okay but the thing is
again he's only he's almost never
stationary I want it to be so that's why
I brought in this car so maybe if we
changed this to about four all right
that's pretty cool yeah he moves any
stationary we could make him not move
diagonally for example that could be
another addition but what you what you
get here is a is basically just this guy
Minds his own business right and I
really like that type of AI okay it's uh
as you can see it's well it's
ridiculously simple to implement but not
only ridiculously simple to implement
it's also really effective it just looks
nice it's good for AI that you just want
to feel your fill your scenery fill your
environment and of course if we wanted
to add more of these if we go to our
spawn level plus if we want to add more
of these instead of adding one dummy we
could actually put this into a for loop
so for int I equals zero eyes lesson 10
for example if you want to add 10 let's
add 10 of these new dummy objects now of
course they will all be separate and
they will all move in different
directions because I'm they
you that they're they're actually new
instances of dummy so if we um check
that out what we get as you can see is a
bunch of just basically ambient guys
here right they're just moving around
minding their own business whatever not
colliding with stuff because I just
don't care and they're pretty simple
right and you know I'm sure you guys
will have a lot of fun with this you
could have like a hundred of these guys
and well yeah and you can probably see
the FPS here it does drop a little bit
but hey there are a lot of guys here but
we're still running it like 2,700 FPS
here so yeah and this will as you can
say this just looks really nice they're
my tits probably too many here but you
know you do get my drift here it is
really nice for creating like some
environment um feel as like yes just
make your map look a lot more alive you
know so that's how that that's how that
works again so that's gonna basically
conclude this episode of game
programming next time we're actually
going to take a look at very very simple
chasing algorithm just in case you guys
are not aware of it of course it's very
very simple but we will um talk a bit
more in detail about how we can improve
that a little bit and after that of
course we're gonna cover waypoints and
after that we're gonna cover the a-star
search algorithm and they'll basically
be our finale for AI for now at least
again then we'll move on to more things
so I hope you guys enjoyed this episode
of game programming if you did again
please hit the like button if we do hit
300 likes that is two videos per day
otherwise 200 likes equals for one video
per day but I do really hope that you
guys are enjoying this these um game
programming episodes as much as I enjoy
making them and you know if you know it
or if you are just leave a comment being
like you know rock on Jonah or something
of the type and apart from that though
guys I will see you next time goodbye
you